you take your schoolwork seriously
obviously you work very hard you're an
entertainer you're in the entertainment
business and blackish those are some
long hours but they're pretty serious
about you going to school too and
there's a there's a teacher on set is
that right yes there is a teacher or
we'd say tutor shout-out to my Tina
Thomas a but you just say he just got
your grade up do you do it alright but
um but like I am part of this program
that I do online homeschool for and I I
got accepted to be in the National
Junior Honor Society last year are you
really cool that's great you know who
didn't get that honor Justin Bieber yeah
I mean I've always been you know growing
up to you know always take a schoolwork
seriously so yeah but it's crazy seeing
always like Anthony Anderson and Tracy
and like Laurens like they've always
like gone to leave right they always let
them leave after they're done filming
like me and some of the other kids on
the show we have to stay extra hours
like you don't understand like we stayed
late you know here's what I want to ask
you it's like do they ever like any
Anthony Anderson I would say he's he's
done for the day
and he's leaving because he sort of put
in your face a little bit like well I
guess I'm gonna go and I'm gonna take
off now and relax enjoy school does he
yeah he always ever since basically the
show started he's always been having his
own model that he's been saying to the
rest of the kids
and he says school is for suckers like
it just punches off of the gut like
really large god bless him right and we
leave at the same time and he left and
he goes in his car and I'm headed
towards school he's headed towards his
car and he's like see you on the other
side school is for suckers
[Applause]
what you don't know is five minutes
later he crashes his car into a mailbox
[Applause]
you